good afternoon we're gonna continue our
program with our luncheon speaker we
thank whoever that was
we of course celebrate another important
anniversary today which is would good to
note which is that in 1796 on this day
will George Washington released his
farewell address in which he announced
his retirement gave his advice on
constitutional government religion and
morality in America's place in the world
often misunderstood that address was
actually about how America should steer
clear of permanent alliances but at the
same time developed the wherewithal the
strength and consistency to give it
humanly speaking the command of its own
fortunes so it's appropriate today that
we conclude our discussions with a
consideration of America's foreign
policy during the election the Donald
Trump campaigned about with the idea of
reshaping American policy to place
America and its interests first in
Warsaw Poland again in Riyadh Saudi
Arabia and I expect today when he speaks
united nation we will hear more of that
Sebastian Gorka served most recently as
deputy assistant and strategist to
President Trump
prior to working the White House he held
the general Horner chair of military
theory at the marine corps University
and was associate dean of congressional
affairs at National Defense University
in Washington DC he was born in United
Kingdom to parents who escaped communist
Hungary he served as a reserve member of
the British Army's Intelligence and
Security Group and now is the United
States citizen he appears frequently in
international media BBC Fox CNN see
MSNBC and Breitbart among others and
he's the author in New York Times
bestseller defeating jihad the winnable
war he speaking say on American
greatness and in America first foreign
policy join me in welcoming Sebastian
cork
[Applause]
good morning ladies and gentlemen never
go anywhere without your copy of him
Primus okay it really is a a high honor
for me to address this August audience
my wife and I have been huge fans of
Hillsdale for many many years and it's
always a race when in Primus hits the
doormat who's going to read it first but
I have a caveat to begin with for the
next thirty minutes please don't expect
a discourse on the Tocqueville in the
epistemology of the New Age my first
degree was philosophy and theology many
moons ago but I cannot match the
erudition of the panels that we heard
this morning I'm going to bring it all
down to earth and share with you my
experiences inside the belly of the
beast as a deputy assistant and
strategist to the president and how we
should move forward and what we can
expect in the years to come but first
things first I must make a plea to all
those people who came up to me last
night and have done so since I left
three weeks ago
relax
take a deep breath and count to ten
the fat lady isn't singing okay I know
that's not politically correct but who
cares we are in this for the long game
I'm going to you know be using
Washington a jargon but this is about
the long game it's not about the first
eight months it's about eight years and
then another eight years under President
pence that's the plan
lots of people got suicidal when my boss
Steve Bannon resigned and then they
really got suicidal when I left the
building
but it's okay bringing us back to the
principles of the founding is not a
function of where Steve sits whether I
have a window in my office in the
Eisenhower building it's a function of
the ideas that brought a man as we were
reminded last night brought a man who
has never held public office before or
been a general flag officer into the
position of being the most powerful man
in the world there is a reason for that
and it is much bigger than a few people
who work in that wonderful people's
house just across the city so hold the
line
the only philosophical thing I'll say is
words matter words matter and the words
for my address today are simple ones the
first one is a phrase common sense the
second one which is allied to common
sense is the word truth and the last one
which is the most important important
philosophical undergirding of everything
that brought Donald Trump into the White
House and informed his policy is the
word sovereignty this is missed by the
people inside the
outweigh these aren't random speeches
the war defeating Isis pulling out of
the Paris climate Accord these are
informed by the same philosophical idea
the importance of sovereignty and the
nation-state so that's all the
philosophizing I will do so let me talk
to you about my experience here for the
last few months inside the White House
I'll talk about three things who is the
president I'll talk about what happened
inside the building and I'll address
this question that has become so popular
today of the deep state and how it
effects foreign policy going forward who
is the president the president behind
closed doors is exactly the same as he
is in public he's not your average
politician who when he sees a camera
flicks a little switch in the back of
his head and then switches on that
Washington grimace he is who he is when
I first met him in the summer 2015 when
I was asked to come brief him in New
York on matters to do with national
security the man in private was exactly
the man I had come to know on the
television screens and that is in itself
refreshing there is no Janis faced
bipolarity
with this individual secondly he is a
Preta natural instinctual actor it is
not an exaggeration monica crowley
described him most accurately the
weekend of the election we were with
David Horowitz and his colleagues at his
restoration weekend which was either
going to be awake or celebration but the
right candidate one and two days after
the election Monica stated the people
who misunderstand Donald J Trump look at
him through an ideological lens
and that is completely the wrong way to
look at him because Donald J Trump
wasn't an ideological candidate he was
an attitudinal
candidate and that is very very much so
you cannot slap easy lazy labels onto
this man yes the chattering classes
would have you do so the mainstream
media would have you do so but remember
this is a Republican candidate who
strode along the campaign platform
waving a gay pride flag that's not
exactly a classic Republican candidate
he breaks the conventional taxonomy and
that's important to remember what he is
is a man who cares about making this
nation great again that slogan is not
pablum it's not empty rhetoric he truly
wishes to translate what he has done in
the private sector in terms of making a
great brand and translating that back to
America's position in the world and its
founding principles what happened in the
last seven months until I left the White
House well what happened on January the
20th needs to be understood who likes
the movie Red Dawn the original one
great movie okay those of you have not
seen it watch it not the remake the
original on November the 8th it was very
much like the movie Red Dawn a scrappy
band of insurgents won against the bear
moth and in this case it was the
establishment Donald J Trump was only
accidentally the GOP candidate he was as
much an anti-establishment
right-wing candidate as an
anti-establishment Democrat candidate he
was the antithesis of the swamp as a
result of wiping the floor with 16
candidates think about that wiping the
floor with 16 establishment candidates
and then trouncing a woman who had spent
700 million dollars for a position she
thought was owed to her as a result of
that unprecedented political event on
China the 20th or 21st 8 o'clock in the
morning when we rolled into the West
Wing it was a hostile takeover and it
has to be understood as such if you look
at the federal government if you add in
the Armed Forces we have two plus
million employees and a couple of dozen
people who are committed to the platform
came in to execute a hostile takeover of
an institution with literally millions
of employees that's not going to be easy
as such we fought a rearguard action
inside the building and at one point for
Steve it was earlier than me he decided
he can be more effective on the outside
he took his decision and then when I
heard the President's speech on
Afghanistan I knew it was time for me to
relocate my desk in my chair I came in
because of my background in
counterterrorism and my commitment to
defeating radical Islamic terrorism and
when a speech was written for the
president which had that phrase removed
after its use multiple times in Riyadh
in front of the joint session of
Congress in Warsaw I knew that the swamp
was in ascendance however very important
to remember this is a temporary state of
affairs I predict within the next few
months we shall see some very
significant changes or personnel at the
highest levels of the administration not
because a cabinet member decides to do
it or a chief of staff but because the
president decides to do it in the last
seven months most of the firings have
had nothing to do with the president in
the next few months I
they will and that is a good thing let's
talk about the deep state I don't like
the phrase the deep state I think it has
a a flavor of conspiracy theory
I love conspiracy theories as fiction
okay I have a bookshelf of them but
there's a reason they're called theories
they're not conspiracy facts okay I
prefer the phrase the permanent state
and that's not a conspiracy theory the
permanent state is real and it is a
problem when you look at the values that
it holds I wasn't part of the National
Security Council but I thanks to some
good people in the NSC I attended
numerous meetings on key issues whether
it was the Qatar crisis whether it was
defeat Isis Muslim Brotherhood and so
forth and to sit I mean look I'm the
child of people who escaped communist
dictatorship my father at the age of 20
was given a life sentence for being an
anti-communist and spent two years in a
prison coal mine so I arrived to
Washington with a sense that I was
adequately cynical I had no idea when
you sit inside the Situation Room well
you sit inside an NSC video conference
facility with members of the interagency
sitting at the table and then
outstations DIA CIA Department of
Defense so on and so forth and you're
talking about a very important policy
issue at the highest level of US
government policy coordination inside
the NSC and you just listen for an hour
hour and a half and not one person in
the room or on the outstations mentions
the name of the president what his
objectives are given the relevant issue
or what he said yesterday in Warsaw we
have a problem Houston especially when
you see that happen again
and again and again and then it's left
up to me the guy with a funny accent to
remind everybody in the room and on the
outstations you do know what the
president said yesterday about Isis well
you do know what he said yesterday about
illegal immigration the lone warped
voice had to remind them that's the
permanent state
it's the gs-15 who's been at the State
Department for twenty years and thinks
he knows better than the individual who
was elected to run the federal
government this is something that will
take years for us to rectify but we
shall second topic I'd like to talk
about is based upon what I heard
yesterday you always plan great speeches
and then you hear people like Professor
on and then you have to throw it all out
and start again so I'd like to address
what the good professor said yesterday
about war and the great lessons we must
learn from true statesmen like Churchill
statecraft is debt we haven't had
statesmen or women since the 1980s as
far as I'm concerned I grew up under
Maggie Thatcher she was a hero to me as
was the Gipper let's just ruminate for a
moment on this word war war is not a
word you wish to use lightly Churchill
was absolutely right but we must
differentiate between different types of
war
we are not in a total war we don't have
children today collecting an aluminium
soda cans so we can build bombers that's
total war however however there are
people who are engaged with war in war
with us right now and that's to begin
with irregular warfare
well groups like Isis and al-qaeda are
doing on the streets of Boston on the
streets of nice on the streets of
Orlando is a form of warfare it's not
total war in the clouds of its Ian sense
but it is war and one of the reasons I
decided to
says the president was in the first five
minutes of meeting him in 2015 I
realized that this is a man who
understands we are at war with a new
totalitarian enemy global jihadism is a
form of totalitarianism it has a
connective tissue it has a shared gene
code with the fascists and the Nazis of
the past with the Communists of the Cold
War
why because you cannot negotiate with
Abu Bakr al Baghdadi just as you cannot
negotiate with Hitler they will either
kill or enslave you period and when I
met Donald Trump I understood
immediately if there's not only a man
who understands we are at war he also
wishes to win that war and that is very
refreshing but there are other forms of
warfare we must be familiar with there
is political warfare and there is
information operations and we are being
targeted right now
I'm not going to get into you know the
Russia collusion delusion but the fact
is or what what is my friend Kellyanne
call it the Russian concussion but the
fact is anybody who is surprised that
Russia wanted to influence an election
in a Western democracy has been asleep
since 1917 that's what the Kremlin does
and the fact is Russia has fine-tuned
the tools it developed during the Cold
War which were called muskie hrothgar
destined for amatzia
and it is using them today in the cyber
domain
this isn't about Hillary this isn't
about Podesta this is about Russia's
tradecraft for the last what is it
hundred years of the anniversary this
year and we must take it seriously we
don't we I can't tell you how many
meetings I've been through in the
Pentagon where when you say the word
political warfare people get all jittery
I mean we did this the OSS wasn't a
Special Forces organization the OSS was
a political warfare
we need to understand who's using it
against us and to respond against it and
then lastly the thing that the scales
fell off my eyes during my months in the
White House thanks to Steve Bannon
because what I learnt about economic
warfare I was brought in to talk about
counterterrorism and represent the
president in the media but if we have a
long-term threat to this nation it's not
the jihadists we will deal with the
jihadists they will be no stone upon
stone left eventually what we have to
understand is what China is doing to us
in the economic domain and the rank
abject surrender that our private sector
especially Silicon Valley and many
politicians in this city have
demonstrated by saying Oh Chinese money
that's like anybody else's money that's
fine their money is green - wrong when
Apple decides to put its latest
artificial intelligence Research Center
in China that means China have
successfully executed economic warfare
against us and we need to take this
seriously if you don't believe me after
this event go home and Google one phrase
one belt one road one belt one road the
Commerce Party of China looks at the
last hundred years as the anomaly in
more than 5000 years of history they see
it as an embarrassment and that it will
return to its rightful place as the
hegemonic power in the world and it has
an overt plan to do so this is not
classified Google it one belt one road
they know how to do strategy and they
are executing on that strategy and the
sooner we wake up the better so where
does that leave us with regards to
future foreign and national security
policy well number one
we must remind ourselves that Francis
Fukuyama was very wrong when that former
neocon wrote I think was in 1991 a
famous book that turned into an article
the end of history in the last man his
argument was a very seductive one we
defeated all the totalitarians we
defeated the fascists when I would
defeat in the Soviet Union
therefore the future of mankind is
determined it was actually quite big
alien argument yes it was the natural
progression of the dialectic he said the
future of mankind is I'm going to date
myself here is simply a question of
twiddling with the buttons on your
graphic equalizer of democracy you're
just going to have to hide true in the
base the treble and and it's there's no
serious threats we've defeated all of
them it's just about fine-tuning his
argument was ideology is dead that's
what we were told in 1991 ideology is
dead I ask you today if you listen to
the President's speech that he gave an
hour ago the UN if you look at North
Korea you look at Venezuela if you look
at Iran if you look of Russia and tell
me that ideology is dead but I'll check
you whether you've got a heartbeat
whether you're breathing ideology is
reborn not in a bipolar sense but there
is a connective tissue that links
Venezuela to Iran to Isis to Russia to
China they're not all communist and all
jihadis but they're one I logical
connection is that they all wish to the
undermine or destroy us Iran I agree
that the threat from North Korea is a
very serious one as we heard last night
but Iran is more serious why because our
last administration facilitated a regime
that wishes to destroy us 150 billion
dollars signed a deal that doesn't stop
them getting nuclear weapons it mildly
delays them
to quote a survivor of the Holocaust an
old man who'd seen his whole family die
in the labor camps and in the death
camps of Auschwitz and Birkenau some
facile reporter asked him one day
what is your take-home from the last six
years of the Holocaust what's what's
your big lessons learned we said oh
that's easy there's one lesson learned
when a group of people repeatedly says
they will destroy you sooner or later
you should take them seriously we need
to take Iran seriously and everybody
else who not only verbally is committed
to our destruction but is working on
ways to acquire the capability to affect
that destruction so we need to
understand that on the right we have
been far too superficial in our
understanding of foreign policy for in
the run-up to the election the reason I
actually agreed to work for Donald Trump
additionally was I'd had enough of
people saying on the right you only have
two options when it comes to national
security you must be in isolation it's
like the libertarians pull down the
shutters on the Pacific coast and
Atlantic coast and we'll be fine just
like we were in Pearl Harbor and the
other option is oh if you don't do that
if you don't be a libertarian you're
going to be a dastardly neocon and
invade everybody's country and create
democracy the end of a gun barrel well
there's a massive scale in between
there's a massive palette of true
statecraft between isolationism and near
conservativism and that's who this
president is I have been in the Oval I'm
not talking out of school but when the
president tells me one on one I do not
wish to go to war with Korea that's
reassuring he understands the
consequences of his actions at the same
time when he sees men and women gassed
death in Syria he's prepared to take
action we didn't talk about red lines we
didn't blow v8 we acted and the day
after that attack
I bumped him to the vice president I was
as I was coming out of the West Wing and
he stopped and he said to me the day
after the cruise missile attack well
first thing he said to me was what do
you think about last night go Navy
seriously he said go Navy and then he
said very seriously so what do you think
do you think they got the message about
gassing unarmed women and children
I said yes mr. vice president I think
the world got the message strategic
patience leading from behind created a
Dantean Inferno across the globe which
we inherited
we understand it's not about reckless
application of force but use of force
when it is needed but only in the
national interest of the United States
that's what America first means I
commend to you I know the individuals
who wrote it if you haven't closely done
so please go back to the president's
Walsall speech because the president's
warsaw speech is a reaffirmation of
judeo-christian civilizational values
and a statement that we will not export
by force our political system but we
will stand shoulder to shoulder with
anyone that shares our judeo-christian
values whether it's Poland or whether
it's Belgium anyone that's who the
president is the impediment along the
way is the managerial elite that's the
biggest obstacle that's the technical
term
for the swamp they have a default
ideology which is really anti national
sovereignty cloaking itself in
postmodern sophistication organizing
like Hillsdale can pierce through that
ideological default setting and remind
us of the existence of objective truth
which i think is the basis of why
blue-collar steel workers in Youngstown
Ohio who were registered Democrats voted
for a billionaire from New York they may
not know the difference between Sunni
and Shia but they know that something is
rotten in the Kingdom of Denmark and
therefore they voted the way they voted
we have to return true statecraft I'm
very excited about what I heard
yesterday the masters in government that
hills there will be pursuing because to
quote one of our greatest presidents for
the time we are living in right now as
our case is new so we must think and you
Abraham Lincoln we must think in you
because this city is as intellectually
bankrupt as it is morally if we do so
then we let me quote in Primus
a speech by a certain presidential
candidate who's now the commander in
chief what is needed in Washington is a
president who will rein in the executive
branch and work with Congress to make
sure the ledge the branch does its job
that is Donald J Trump's objective and
if we help him to be successful if
Hillsdale can help him to be successful
if the graduates sorted across the
administration can help him to be
successful then we will be able once
more to secure the blessings of liberty
to ourselves in our prosperity
[Applause]
dr. Gorka has some time for some
questions we do have microphones if you
would raise your hand and direct them
towards us that would be
sebastien great speech appreciate it I
do have one question which is still
unresolved in my mind is that why I mean
I would feel I would feel safer if you
and Banyan were in the White House and
the gs-15 who have been in the federal
government for twenty years are not in
the White House it seems to me things
are somewhat reversed and I don't quite
understand why the guy who has the power
to hire and fire and certainly doesn't
know the meaning the word fire why the
gs-15 is still there
and you're not does anybody think that
the president United States deals with
HR actions for gs-15
I mean come on a common sense please
right the president deals with cabinet
members and then signs off on people
that are assistance in deputies the idea
that the president is going to go
through with a you know a broad brush
and and sweep out the detritus of the
permanent state is just fallacious I
mean this man has enough on his plate
already
but let's talk about Steve Bannon and
myself when when Steve resigned I was on
vacation when he resigned of course the
left was just coruscating excitement
across of left I mean they're they're
holding parties into the wee hours
that's the van and had left the White
House
you do realize that once Steve Bannon
resigned he became the most powerful man
in America outside of the West Wing do
you know that yes I mean the left has no
idea what they're talking about the idea
that he's unshackled from the
requirements incumbent upon a US
government employee I mean if I got
three TV interviews in a week
representing the president I was a good
week
the day after I resigned I had 20 yes I
mean this is this is the reality there
are things you can do legal things less
politico's listening there are things
that you can do outside of government
that you simply cannot do as a
politically commissioned officer of the
president so the president reached out
to me the day after I resigned he said
thank you for your work
he said I am going to stay on my agenda
I would like you to support me from the
outside and that's exactly what I am
doing and Steve is doing with a far
larger palette of tools available to us
and if we'd stayed in the building and I
predict and look it's not it's not about
me or Steve going back into the
administration I predict in the months
and years to come you will see people
who have been indelibly identified with
the president's original victorious
message who will be coming into the
building not only that the fact that
individuals like Corey Lewandowski David
bossy were walking in and out of the
Oval Office freely and they didn't work
for the government who do you think what
what do we think they were talking about
with the president the weather the
president is very loyal to those who
have been loyal to him
so again deep breath count to 10 it's
okay
[Applause]
dr. Gorka thank you so much so I did a
little research
my numbers may be off but bear with this
and you can and then elucidate so in
1800 the first census there were eight
point three million people in the
country a hundred and twenty-five people
in the executive branch
fast forward to you know where we go
with this you fast forward to 2015 if I
remember the numbers right population is
like 320 million so it's fifty three and
a half times the original population the
administrative state the executive
branch was 2.9 million so that went up
twenty one thousand two hundred times
for the fifty three times of population
how do we how are we ever gonna I mean I
have patients it'll take time but we
always hear we never hear about this
thing decreasing I think the president
tried to cut EPA and stuff like 30
percent but who knows if that will get
through Congress it so easily it always
grows and it grows and it grows how does
it stop there's a great history of that
yeah your point is well-taken
Eisenhower I hate this
this idea that you hear all the time and
the war colleges and across you know the
think tanks the world is so complicated
today it's so much more complicated than
anybody ever had to dull deal with
before I mean do we really think the
president in 1948 had an easy time we
just lost losing China Berlin Blockade
60 million people killed in World War
two the idea that just because you have
an iPhone the world is more complicated
is again bad thinking okay Eisenhower's
National Security Council
Eisenhower not a calm time in history
was twenty five people we inherited from
President Obama an MSc of four hundred
and twenty people so yes a lot of work
has to be done but individual I'm not
gonna give away names but in the watch
what individual cabin that cabinet
members are doing individual cabinet
members very quietly are doing very
interesting things that are the less
sexy portfolios that will tell you the
commitment to taking on the
administrative state but you are right
it will take time thank you you
mentioned the problem of Apple moving
operations to China yes what can we do
about that
no seriously I mean look in my book
defeating jihad people was asking so
what can I do what can I do I mean I I I
never in you know enlisted I can't teach
at a war college can I do anything to
help and I say absolutely the first
appendix in my book is what you can do
in the war against the new totalitarians
and the first thing you can do is
educate everyone around you don't just
wait for Hillsdale to do it I mean at
the watercooler
at the you know the the 4th of July
barbecue in your in your neighborhood
educate people on the reality my friend
in the White House coined the term fake
news industrial complex and it's a great
phrase I mean I thought I was adequately
cynical about the media I had no idea I
spent just seven months in office one
journalist one journalist alone wrote 45
attack pieces on me one they attacked
the reputation of my dead mother
they attacked my wife they attacked my
teenage high school song this is what we
have to deal with so you have a massive
role to play in cutting through that not
by getting preachy or standing on a
soapbox but when somebody says the
Russian the Russians and all this about
Trump just ask them so what exactly are
you talking about the the 20% of the
uranium but Hillary agreed to sell to
the company that was giving her husband
a five hundred thousand dollar speaking
fee I mean that Russian collusion are
you talking about the DNC sending an
operative to the embassy of the Ukraine
not just to collect filth on our
campaign but to coordinate an attack
against our campaign you mean that
collusion just helped push back on the
lies on the spin on whatever topic it is
if you have a passion for economics
during economics I mean a million drops
have been unleashed in just a few months
yeah I mean can you can we remember a
Nobel laureate a wacky left-wing Nobel
laureate predicted that if Donald Trump
wins the election I mean this is just
ontologically insane
he said the stock market will suffer a
crash it will likely never recover from
sorry what never mean we stopped selling
shares how does that work
never recover from what are we at the
twenty-ninth stock market record for the
Dow historic record not since January
since we've been counting that's how bad
Donald Trump is for the US economy and
oh well that's about rich stockholders
and it's about your 401 K that's how you
push back anybody who's got a pension
fund what happens on the Dow is good for
you you don't have to be a CEO of IBM
it's good for all Americans and this is
something I learnt from working with the
man and you can't convince through
personal experience but perhaps I can
share with you my understanding and
perhaps through osmosis it will bleed
through this man a number one this is
very important this man does not have a
racist bone in his body
Donald a Donald J Trump hand on heart
give me a Bible I will swear in it
does not have a racist bone in his body
the idea that we are the anti-semites we
are the racists when his grandchildren
our Orthodox Jews is an utter outrage
helped us to push back on these smears
secondly and this is from personal
experience this man because of what he
believes in in what we are as a nation
he wants every single America in our
great nation to thrive and prosper even
if you voted for Hillary he wants you to
thrive and prosper he's not vindictive
he believes that everybody's boat can
rise it's not as American greatness is
not a zero-sum game for the president
and that's it that's an important bumper
sticker kind of level message to get out
there so please help us yes would you
elaborate a bit on the relationship with
Russia specifically does your view does
your call for a new statecraft include
the possibility of tactical alliances
here and there with Russia okay so what
is Russia Russia great not to be a
government employee Russia there was the
last press conference was the last press
conference of President gave in Trump
Tower you remember when he I think he
handed over his company to his children
and as he was leaving a press conference
there's somebody from the peanut gallery
shout it out what about Putin what about
the Kremlin the Russian manias was
beginning the present stopped looked at
the journalists and gave the best
two-sentence answer on the White House
and Russia this was true then is true
now and will be true for as long as he
as the president the president replied
in theory I would like to have good
relations with Moscow right now doesn't
look too likely if that is the case so
be it
that's
it end of story the president is a
patriot and a pragmatist
he is the melding of those two things so
he says I would like to have better
relations with Russia why because they
have 5,000 nuclear warheads open a Atlas
there are very few geostrategic nations
in the world Russia by dint of its
location and size is a nation of
geopolitical and geostrategic import not
to have good relations with it is on
why's he said many times we are not
interested in having new enemies however
however in the cold the cold light of
day its actions with its neighbor
Ukraine its actions in propagating
disinformation and misinformation at a
grand scale means that it will be
difficult if not impossible to have
better relations with them why not
because there are existential threat to
America you think a Russia loses 600,000
people more each year than are born I
mean they lose a large city who die you
know with you know cirrhosis and you
name it then are born it's in it's in a
democratic death spiral so it's not an
existential threat to America it is a
spoiler it is a spoiler and it is an
anti status co-actor the president would
like to have good relations doesn't look
likely if that is a case so be it
nothing more nothing less
excellent question thank you one more
question
yeah to keep on track with our schedule
this will be our last question of this
good Rick ruse Indiana I told you
privately I appreciate the fact you do
you don't buy the premise most of the
time of the drive-by media and I really
do appreciate that but as far as the
vindictiveness people have committed
crimes that they aren't being held
accountable for including the nominee of
the Democrat Party
my boys all went to Hillsdale they
learned about justice it does not seem
like justice is being done by the fact
the FBI's adapter corrupt and the DOJ
right now just doesn't seem like you
know we'd rather investigate the
Russians then people that actually Lois
Lerner the former head of the IRS I mean
they're guilty
I think but doesn't seem like anything's
happening I know I'm in flyover country
but you know I can still read the paper
Thanks you're welcome rule of law is
crucial absolutely I can't go into
details but there are at least when it
comes to what was my primary concern of
administration was the national security
leaks we have close to 2,000 criminal
referrals that the DOJ is currently
handling so that's not bad that's not
bad so again patience I know we all want
to see you know bad people get their
just desserts but there is a system we
must follow the system and attorney
General Sessions is a serious man and
things are in the works we shall see but
stay the course thank you our president
arm thank you everybody
[Applause]